hey everyone so here and in the next few
videos i'm going to be talking about
tangent planes
of graphs
and i'll specify that this is tangent
planes of graphs and not of some other
thing because in different contexts of
multi-variable calculus you might be
taking a tangent plane of say a
parametric surface or something like
that but here i'm just focused on graphs
so in the single variable world you
a common problem that people like to ask
in calculus is you have some sort of
curve and you want to find at a given
point what the tangent line to that
curve is what the tangent line is and
you'll find the equation for that
tangent line and this gives you various
information kind of how to let's say you
wanted to approximate the function
around that point it turns out to be a
nice simple approximation and in the
multivariable world it's actually pretty
similar in terms of geometric intuition
it's almost identical you'll have some
kind of graph of a function like the one
that i have here and instead of having a
tangent line because the line is a very
one-dimensional thing and here it's a
very two-dimensional surface
instead you'll have some kind of tangent
plane so this is something where it's
just going to barely be kissing the
graph in the same way that the tangent
line just barely kisses the function
graph
in the one-dimensional circumstance and
it could be at various different points
rather than just being at that point you
could kind of move it around and say
that okay it'll just barely be kissing
the graph of this function but at
different points
and usually the way that a problem like
this would be framed if you're trying to
find such a tangent plane
is first
you think about the the specified input
that you want so in the same way that
over in the single variable world what
you might do is say okay what is the
input value here and maybe you'd name it
like x sub o and then you're going to
find the graph of the function that
corresponds to kind of just kissing the
graph at that input point over here in
the multivariable world
kind of move things about
you'll choose some kind of input point
like this little red dot and that could
be at various different spots it you
know doesn't have to be where i put it
you could imagine putting it somewhere
else but once you decide on where
what input point you want um you see
where that is on the graph so you kind
of go and say oh that input point
corresponds to such and such a height so
in this case it actually looks like
the graph is about zero at that point so
the output of the function would be zero
and what you want is a plane that's
tangent right at that point so you'll
draw some kind of plane that's tangent
right at that point
and if we think about what this what
this input point corresponds to it's not
x sub o a single variable input like we
have in the single variable world but
instead that red dot that you're seeing
is going to correspond to
some kind of input pair x sub o and y
sub o
so the ultimate goal over here in our
multivariable circumstance is going to
be to find some kind of new function so
i'll i'll write it down here some kind
of new function that i'll call l for
linear that's going to take in x and y
and we want the graph of that function
to be this plane and you might specify
that it's this is dependent on the
original function that you have and
maybe you also specify that it's
dependent on this input point in some
way but the basic idea is we're going to
be looking for a function whose graph is
this plane tangent at a given point and
in the next couple videos i'm going to
talk through how you actually compute
that it might seem a little intimidating
at first because how do you control a
plane in three dimensions like this but
it's actually very similar to the single
variable circumstance and you just kind
of take it one step at a time
see you next video